first question do you believe in aliens
do you believe in aliens uh we do we do
we're saying it as a United States yeah
I love this we do we do we do we agree
on that we'd agree we have agreed on
this listen we do perfect no judgment
yeah I agree yeah and would you say the
asteroid City I don't know kind of
resembles a little place you might have
heard of area 51.
oh we agreed that it does yeah we agree
on that yes we said it did okay we're
two for two
I love it
I love this yeah
if you get one wrong and it switches
over to me and it's my turn you keep
asking questions
all right okay
well listen I watching this film I
had like a love note
to theater to each of you to the
Artistry would you agree like what was
it what was it like playing these
characters and and the vibe on set
it I I think that's one of the things
about the movie that I really
um I don't know I find very touching is
you know Wes is such a lover of the
camaraderie between actors and like the
environment that we create and work in
um that is probably only appropriate
amongst actors and like no other
workplace okay
it's probably to roll like in our bodies
and whatnot but um yeah it's it's uh you
know you really see that uh Affinity in
this I think it's sort of you know you
had said it that
but when we were all watching the
screening together he in can he just
said it was the most fun he'd had
watching it with all the actors uh we
were all in these two rows together and
he was sort of in the middle he just
said it made me so happy it was to watch
it with all of the actors because it's
four actors so it's incredibly sweet
that's incredible well I mean listen
this stack is like this cast is stacked
okay like there are so many beautiful
people in this community I feel like
you had to have some fun moments right
is there one standout moment for you
that you just are gonna carry with you
throughout life well we definitely
had a whole you know the West creates
this atmosphere on the set
um and then it's also there's a whole
other
environment that he creates offset so
we're all staying together in the same
place like we all eat our eat all our
meals together we you know the work like
the work doesn't leave we don't leave
work when we leave work you know we're
still it's not like hard though is that
hard or it's good no you always kind of
want to be at least I felt this way I
was like am I missing something I'd go
back to my room throw down my script bag
and all that stuff and then like
immediately run downstairs because I
didn't want to miss a fun moment
um it was really exciting but I don't
know I'm you're not jaded to that oh my
God I I uh I mean I have a similar thing
which is if I I would come home and if I
didn't run down I would open my windows
just to hear people and look Courtyard
because it was all we were all because
because what they're taught not to
eavesdrop I mean just because you're
just like wow this is it's rare to have
it's a it's a rare opportunity to have a
cast like this all that is all together
hanging out that does all support each
other that is really nice and and do get
along it's rare to have a set that's
built like on a giant piece of property
it's just you know and I think that's a
testament to Wes I think it's why you
one should strive to do the best job
they can because it can help you do more
jobs the way you'd like to do them and I
think that's why everyone's everyone's
sitting there
um because of
he worked because he cares um that's
really special it's beautiful
well I have to say there are a lot of
different Dynamics within this film
it speaks to a lot of different
relationships
um one of them being motherhood
and I know that you went back to work
eight weeks postpartum Scarlett
isn't that that's correct yes yes I did
yeah as a mom
um I also experienced the same thing and
so I'm wondering you know
was that were there any challenges in
getting into this role or did it help
you chat like capture that character
um yeah I mean I was I hadn't so I was
yeah I had a little baby which was
great to be able to share with everybody
because how often you get to be around
like an eight-week-old baby so everybody
was very excited about that because it's
so amazing you know they're like this
new fresh person
um and I I was I was so happy you know I
just was I was very fortunate that I
felt really great after I had my son and
so I was excited to share him with
everybody and um and it was it was fun
for me to be there was something about
being all a little bit out of my mind
that was actually kind of helpful I
think because I you know I feel like
when you're a new parent you know you're
in a dream waking dream state a lot of
the time like the first
few months you know four months or so
till you kind of get it down and
um and so it I liked that like for it
helped in a way the
surreal quality of the
work that we were doing you know yeah it
was fun as a mom I have to commend you
because I think it just shows your
strength I think it shows how Fierce you
are you're just even better as a moment
you're welcome oh yeah no I I mean it's
uh you know I I have a lot of friends
that are uh you know that have gone back
to work out after having a baby you know
eight weeks 10 weeks 12 weeks postpartum
and it's definitely you know I was very
fortunate that I got to I work in an
environment where I can bring my baby to
work you know I know a lot of women that
are pumping milk in the coffee break
room and you know like that's really
it's very challenging so I I'm lucky
that I got you know that I got to have
my baby with me and my in my little
dressing area and stuff like that not
everybody gets that I know it made it
easier for me awesome and you were such
an incredible support I I heard you say
that he he was amazing I didn't do it no
because Jason was there he needed him
for desperately I was thrown into it but
we you know our work together is so
um you know it was it was so exciting
because we you know was so connected we
got to you know bring it to life with
Wes they're witnessing in and it was
like this kind of missing piece because
it was done at the end of the production
so it felt really yeah really yeah
exciting very cool very cool I mean
you're a vet you're exactly you didn't
want uh I was gonna ask you about your
baby was there anyone you were like
actually give me the baby back yes yes I
don't know if you really got the baby
touch Rupert
[Laughter]
[Music]
amazing well thank you so much for your
time I appreciate it I appreciate it so
excited for the world to see this this
is so good so good yeah thank y'all